este parece un problema interesante
tenemos aquí un polígono que parece un
pentágono tiene cinco lados pero un
pentágono irregular porque no todos los
lados miden lo mismo bueno al menos eso
parece y los lados continúan entonces
tenemos ángulos exteriores que se forman
en este pentágono y se nos pregunta cuál
es la suma de todos estos ángulos
exteriores entonces bueno pero está raro
porque como puedes ver no nos dan más
información ni siquiera nos están dando
la medida de los otros ángulos así que
de qué punto partimos aquí lo que
podemos hacer es ir paso a paso y
basándonos en lo que sí sabemos veamos
aquí tenemos estos ángulos exteriores y
cada uno de ellos es suplementario a un
ángulo interior así bueno si lo desees
pensamos como una función de ángulos
interiores podríamos quizás escribir
este problema de una manera que resulte
más sencillo de resolver entonces
tenemos aquí hasta la letra
tenemos ángulos hasta la letra n y
llamemos a este ángulo interior
efe a este ángulo interior g
a este h a este y a este j entonces la
suma de estos ángulos exteriores a esa
hora lo mismo que 180 menos g porque hay
que son ángulos suplementarios entonces
hay lo mismo que 180 menos g 180 menos g
más b entonces bueno pero b lo podemos
ver cómo lo podemos escribir en términos
de este ángulo interior será 180 menos h
entonces aquí tenemos más 180 menos h
porque una vez más estos ángulos son
suplementarios y bueno hagamos lo mismo
para cada uno de los ángulos es lo mismo
que 180 menos y entonces 180 menos y
luego de lo podemos escribir como 180
menos j ajá más 180 menos j y finalmente
es igual a 180 menos f entonces más 180
efe y lo que nos queda ahora bueno si
sumamos todos los ángulos 180 tenemos
185 veces entonces esto es igual a 5 por
ciento 80 lo cual es igual a qué cosa es
como 900 más o menos si de hechos 900
entonces tienes menos g - h - y menos j
y menos efe
o podríamos escribir esto como menos que
más h lo voy a hacer el mismo color
bueno eso no es el mismo color entonces
bueno usaré los los mismos colores estoy
factor izando este signo menos entonces
gemas h más y
+ j
+ j + efe y la razón por la que hice
esto más efe la razón por la que hice
esto es porque bueno lo que lo que es
interesante aquí es que exprese esto en
términos de la suma de los ángulos
interiores entonces será 900 menos todo
este asunto así que estos 5 por 180 es
900 menos todo esto y esto es la suma de
los ángulos interiores lo escribo para
tenerlo bien presente entonces es la
suma de los ángulos interiores y parece
que progresamos un poco si podemos
averiguar la suma de los ángulos
interiores bueno qué mejor así que para
hacer esto te voy a mostrar un pequeño
truco lo que quieres hacer es dividir
este polígono el interior de este
polígono en tres triángulos que no se
solapen así que lo podemos hacer desde
cualquier vértice digamos que desde este
vértice está muy bien y mejor lo pongo
en otro color baja que te parece blanco
entonces aquí se forma uno de los
triángulos y después pongo esto esta
otra línea y se forman ya los tres
triángulos
así que ya dividimos este polígono en
tres triángulos que no
no se solapan y la razón por la que esto
es válido es porque si sabemos cuál es
la suma de los ángulos internos de un
triángulo y para que eso nos funcione
tenemos que expresar estos ángulos en
términos de la suma de la suma de los
ángulos porque la suma de los ángulos
internos de un triángulo es de 180
entonces que ya es uno de los ángulos de
este triángulo efe se reparte en dos
ángulos porque bueno de esto
efe es todo este ángulo entonces voy a
dividir a efe en otros dos ángulos o
mejor dicho en otras dos medidas de
ángulos lo voy a llamar digamos que f es
igual
digamos que
efe es igual ya tenemos hasta la letra
tenemos a b c d e f g h i j
no hemos usado la k aún entonces f es
igual a k y l cama cl efe es igual a la
suma de estos dos ángulos adyacentes k
más l y ahí ya tenemos otros dos ángulos
de este triángulo podemos hacer lo mismo
para para j entonces hagamos lo mismo
para el ángulo j con el ángulo j&j es
todo esto entonces podemos dividir a
jota jota es igual ya usamos el entonces
jota es igual a m más n m más n acá lo
pongo jota es igual a m n y finalmente
podemos dividir al ángulo h h es todo
esto entonces podemos decir que h es
igual a o más p más q esto es o esto es
p y esto es q y recuerda yo quiero
dividir estos ángulos interiores para ya
tener ángulos con nombre en estos
triángulos entonces tenemos aquí qué
es igual acá lo escribo h es igual a más
q y eso es interesante porque ahora
podemos escribir la suma de estos
ángulos interiores como la suma de un
montón de ángulos que son parte de estos
triángulos luego podemos usar el hecho
de que la suma de los ángulos internos
de un triángulo es de 180 así que
entonces hagamos esto en esta expresión
esta expresión aquí tenemos que entonces
voy a escribir aquí que aunque aunque no
mejor mejor voy a escribir todo así que
tenemos 900 menos y ahora si pongo
entonces que más y en lugar de h puedo
poner que es igual a más p más q
entonces más o más p más q luego más y
entonces aquí voy a poner más y
y luego más jota pero jota estoy usando
los colores correctos o no creo que ya
no sé entonces jota es esta expresión
jota es igual a msn entonces más m más n
y finalmente tenemos aquí efe a que es
igual de ff lo dividimos en dos ángulos
aquí podemos ver
efe es igual acá más l y lo único que yo
hice aquí puede reescribir esta parte en
términos de estos ángulos ahora por
atención porque algo interesante está a
punto de suceder aquí voy a hacer magia
matemática así que ya sabemos cuál es la
suma de estos ángulos sabemos que gemas
camas
es igual a 180 son la suma de los
ángulos internos para este primer
triángulo este primer triángulo gemas
camas o es igual a 180 lo voy a escribir
acá en un nuevo color para este
triángulo sabemos qué
más o más acá es igual a 180 la suma de
estos tres es igual a 180
y bueno entonces voy a escribir otro
color
ya sabemos también que sabemos que para
este triángulo del medio p más el m es
igual a 180 entonces temas de demás m es
igual a 180 temas en ser es igual a 180
de estos tres más 180 y finalmente
sabemos que para este último triángulo
también la suma de sus ángulos internos
q mas n más y es igual a 180 así que
para este triángulo tenemos que comas n
más y es igual a 180 grados así que
sigue aquí sabemos que la suma de los
ángulos internos para un pentágono
irregular bueno de hecho para cualquier
pentágono será de ciento ochenta 180 180
lo cual es igual a 540 y si queremos la
suma para este bueno estos 540 si
queremos dar la suma de los ángulos
externos simplemente los restamos de 900
así que 900 menos 540 es simplemente 360
grados y eso
esa es la respuesta 360 grados